what's going on guys national master
james cantor iii here with chess.com and
today
we have game of the day with the
computer chess championships
with the white pieces we have komodo and
with the black pieces we have leela
chess
zero let's get right into it here we go
e4 and e5
knight f3 knight c6 bishop c4 and bishop
c5
an italian game a joko piano a quiet
game many names to this
but sometimes these games aren't as
quiet as they say they are
after bishop c5 there's c3 here
intending d4
just getting a big center threatening a
bishop that's already out developed
now after knight f6 we're just saying
hey play d4 anyway and if you capture
capture we might just go bishop b4 check
and take on e4 and have a good game now
after d3 which is the more positional
just
slow methodical way of playing i'm going
to get my pieces out and then i'm going
to try to push d4 eventually
even expanding on the queen side with
moves like b4 and a4
so after d3 d6 we're just going to push
upon in the center
lock the bishop outside the pawn chain
like the light square bishop did
as well and open our bishop up for
potential attacks
castles and then a6 here very
multi-purpose type move here
b5 but also the biggest thing is
bringing the bishop back to a7
and we're going to sit here and be a
monster for forever
as long as the bishop e3 doesn't come in
now rook to e1 and then bishop to a7 he
does or she
leela chess actually brings the bishop a
back to a7 here
and eyeing this big diagonal what we
call here is a snake
in the grass guys if you don't see the
snake in the grass and you step on it or
you come near it
what's going to happen it will bite you
you wouldn't even know it so this bishop
here
is doing exactly that sitting from the
other side of the board
a4 expanding on the queen side stopping
queen side expansion um and tempo
well for black here which which would be
b5 so a force blade and then castles and
h3 stopping bishop g4 and also knight g4
which could be extremely annoying
and if bishop to e3 would easily just
take with our knight so
h3 is played and then bishop to e6 you
would sometimes you would see h6 here
more of the human-like move this is why
they call it a quiet game
because they kind of do the same moves
back and forth minus the knight and the
pawn being in different squares here
if this would be absolutely symmetrical
if the knight was on c3
but there's this knight on c6 and the
pawn on c3 makes it just slightly
different so instead of h6 bishop to e6
here guys and this is something that you
can take uh for your own games
so that you can understand what you're
playing and then actually have better
games here bishop to e6
is not the scariest looking move it
honestly is a very good move guys and if
bishop takes
well don't worry about the double pawns
here as you see we already have the rook
file and the bishop
here as well our in the f2 square
indirectly as an x-ray but also the
center pawns actually give
extra protection and we can undouble our
pawns later with a move like d5
and then we have actually a strong
sensor while opening the f file it's a
very strong move here from leela chest
zero
bishop to a6 and knight to a3 here
saying that if you capture i'm just
going to bring my knight to c4 so that's
why they say sometimes to take is a
mistake
you don't always want to just capture
just because there is a capture there as
you see bishop takes e6 was not played
just yet and then h6 here now we're like
okay you know what no bishop g5s
no knight g5s at all so we play h6 and
now surprising move actually bishop
takes e6 is now on board
then after f takes e6 there's a lot of
play for black here
uh of course d5 is a move you also have
the open rook file here so there's
things that you have to watch out for
with the white pieces
and then b4 from komodo b4 is a just an
expansion move on the on the
queen side of the board maybe playing c4
bishop b2 even b5
just to get some space and then here we
go we break open with d5 says leela
chest 0 here
now this pawn is hanging guys chest is
simple math two
versus one so of course white's gonna
win this pawn but that's at a cost
if something like e takes d5 and e takes
d5 then knight takes e5
and the knight takes e5 we have bishop
takes f2 then king takes f2 and knight
g4
with a double check and also a discovery
on the e5 let's actually put that on the
board here
so you guys could see that bishop takes
f2 knight to g4 with a double check
nasty here and after the king moves
knight takes e5
ouch right so that's very scary and and
also looking at this position the pawns
are now
very very strong e4 could be a threat
and again guys this is a very very
a realistic threat something's going on
here on this diagonal so instead of
taking on d5
we see queen to e2 here actually just
defending getting the queen off of the
file as well maybe putting some extra
pressure here let's see what happens
knight h5 beautiful move here from leela
chess zero i really like this move here
guys
intending moves like knight to f4 and
knight to g3 and also opening the rook
file let's see what happens next
rook to b1 here just putting a rook on
the file getting some extra pressure
here
play on the side that you're strongest
on and white is strongest on the queen
side right now
so there is some queen play there and
queen side play
knight to g3 beautiful move here um
intending i'm just hitting the queen
very simple but you cannot
take my knight because the snake on the
other side of the board
will bite you and also it's just an
illegal move but the bishop here is
actually doing a great job so knight g3
is actually a beautiful move
queen to a2 here guys and here we go
it's about to get crazy
black to move what would you actually do
in this position
here we go guys monstrous move brook
takes f3
it's on the board it's there what are
you gonna do with life now
well in this position you literally have
to take the road because there's nothing
else to do
so now you're just here now we have gone
down this rabbit hole here and we have
to go through it no matter what happens
we don't know if we're going to come out
dead or alive here let's see what
happens rook takes f3 g
takes f3 you got to have to you have to
take that there and then we follow up
with a strong move especially if you do
a sacrifice
you should always try to follow up with
very strong moves sometimes you have
quiet moves that you need to make or
quiet connectors to make the whole
combination work
but here this is actually a very strong
move queen f6 intending easy move queen
f3
okay bishop b3 we have to get rid of
this bishop this bishop is the problem
piece on the board we have to get rid of
it so
we just move out of the way because our
knight is hanging now leela chess plays
knight to h5
and if we do remove the bishop here the
f4 square is now forever
ours it's going to be a long time for
this knight to try to capture ours and
if even a rook
it's going to be hard to get this knight
off of f4 and it's also delivering
checkmating threats knight h5 he takes
d5 intending pawn takes and queen takes
d5 with check
and leela chess joe just moves out of
the way he had no checks for you you can
have a second pawn if you like
97 and then komodo's like you're going
to give it to me i'm going to take it i
don't know what's going on here
pawn takes e6 but this this is blocked
so we don't have to worry too much about
this
here we go guys queen h4 and tinging
queen takes h3
maybe rook f8 rook f5s or knight f4 this
is about to get crazy here
bishop takes a7 and should i take the
bishop back or what should i play here
in this position
bishop takes a7 is on the board guys
most people
just take the bishop back i mean take
your piece keep material even
but not leela zero we don't care about
material even gary kasparov
says that activity trumps material most
times so if your piece are active
if your pieces are very active material
sometimes doesn't matter you do need
pieces to help with this wind
but at the same time if you have
something better when you find a good
move
look for a better move like emmanuel
asker says bishop takes a7
queen takes h3 guys knight knight f4 is
coming so you have to do something
rookie four looks good
that's what happens because knight at
four i'm just going to chop that knight
and have a nice day because you got two
mini pieces over here
attacking my king and then rook to f8 so
we're going to bring another piece into
the game
actually knight f4s all kind of things
are happening now here
knight to c4 was the move but actually i
think bishop c5 according to stockfish
was the best move here
but knight to c4 and knight f4 okay it's
it's coming guys it
mates on the board we have to do
something now instead of rook takes f4
what happened here was actually knight
to e3 here's a beautiful move guys black
to move
to have you done your tactics today
puzzle rush all of that good stuff guys
what would you do with the black pieces
now black to move
here we go guys a special move rook f5
and live rook f5 and live if you take my
rook obvious reasons queen to g2
and now we have a third piece in the
game usually it takes two to three
pieces
usually three for a successful attack
sometimes you need to sacrifice one
in this case it would be the rook and
you mate with the other two which is
knight in the queen so the more pieces
the better here
but rick f5 is a beautiful move
intending rook g5 checkmate in a few
here
so after rook takes f4 because he has to
get rid of this rook
i'm going to play
what do you think you're going to play
what are you going to play what are you
going to play
rook ace 5 i'm not going to take
anything
i'm not going to take any piece on the
board i'm going to play rook h5
and we're live game's over what do you
do nothing queen to d5
queen of d5 giving up my queen was the
best move i could find here
says komodo but it doesn't matter
because queen h1 is checkmate
and have a nice day beautiful game here
another attacking
monstrous engine genius game here guys
something that you can take away from
this game again
is absolutely using this f file like how
lila chest did here
beautiful sacrificing on f3 playing
queen f6 with the follow-up move
not caring about material 97 i mean we
sacrificed the rook
then gave up two pawns i mean gave up a
bishop here
and destroyed i mean absolutely
beautiful chess here
sacrificing another piece i mean almost
like leela chess
and tal are best friends absolutely this
is absolutely
ridiculous here beautiful play beautiful
play and after rook takes instead of
taking it back like most people would
maybe even rook takes or pawn takes pawn
takes runs in the night takes
so maybe rook takes rook g5 rook g4
but rook h5 there's nothing that you can
do to stop the checkmate on h1
beautiful even rook h4 we just take it
and go back to may here guys
this was a beautiful game a beautiful
monstrous computer game that we watched
here today guys
and that is awesome so i hope you guys
enjoyed the video i'm national master
james canty the third here with
chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video